[Music]
[Applause]
tiger woods caddy joe lacava
i said we'd love to have you recap what
happened at the british open how
emotional that was walking up 18.
i said we would like to have tiger but
if we can't then we'd love to have you
joe and joe a long time caddy
said that he is going to be available to
talk about that emotional moment with
tiger woods so he'll join us coming up
on the program tomorrow not as emotional
but maybe just as informative dave
mcmenamin espn nba reporter who joins us
on the program and uh
you were at the drew league was there
any mention that kyrie was going
definitely going to be there
um or was just speculation
yeah dan i never heard in terms of
definitive but i did get in touch with
the long time commissioner of the julie
dino smiley on saturday morning and he
told me not only the expectation of
kyrie playing but the game time that he
was slotted to appear in he was supposed
to play at 11 a.m lebron playing at 1 45
p.m
uh i i got to the gym right around the
time that lebron's game was about to
start i was told that kyrie did not in
fact show up but now the plan had been
shifted where they expected kyrie to
show up at the game
after lebron's game
that didn't happen either
now i will say that he was
posted to social media
helping out at a girls skills camp about
55 miles away in thousand oaks and so it
wasn't like he was a complete no-show
and doing something you know no one
knows he was working with youth in terms
of basketball so it's a great use of his
time but that message was never relayed
to the dru league that he was not going
to be showing up i thought that it was a
bigger story that he's working out with
phil handy a laker assistant coach than
going to the drew league dave
yeah i mean there are some breadcrumbs
there to feast upon dan and obviously he
has a history with still handy five
years together with the cleveland
cavaliers but phil for the last several
years has been back in los angeles and
there's a strong relationship there and
we will see what comes of it now i i
think you need more than a relationship
to get this deal done on the lakers side
and thus far uh in my reporting it's
been the nets have been reticent to make
any move with kyrie until they have
figured out what they're going to do
with kevin durant and thus far it's been
a stalemate on the kevin durant front
i keep saying that it seems best for
kevin durant to stay there that he got
everything that he wanted and if you can
get rid of kyrie and kind of make this
truly your own team
and and plus it's going to be difficult
for him to go to a team that doesn't
decimate the roster um and he's not
going to be able to go to miami or
or phoenix perhaps so
i i don't know i'm just trying to figure
all of this out and nobody has told me
why kevin durant wants out of brooklyn
can you fill in some of the blanks there
dave
the only thing that i've reported on
that i have heard repeatedly
from folks is that and you talked about
the emotion of tiger woods at the open
and there was some emotion going on in
kevin durant's
mind seeing the golden state warriors
his former team win the championship and
it caused him to take some stock at
where he is in brooklyn at this moment
and think about where he is in his
career overall he's going to be
considered one of the greatest scorers
of all time one of the greatest players
of all time but we do measure the greats
in the nba when it comes to
championships and he only has two right
now
and looking ahead at the final stage of
his prime and wondering if he can get it
done in brooklyn and
that was the impetus i've been told that
led to the trade request but
i think your statement about wondering
if he could have the team without kyrie
that's another piece of information that
people around the league have speculated
to me that that could have been the true
underpinning of what this trade request
was about it was
i need to be in a situation where i can
win
and compete for championships while i'm
in brooklyn and playing with kyrie
irving doesn't allow me to do that
because of this unreliability so let's
figure something out and thus far
they've already gotten better around the
margins getting tj warren from the
pacers was a nice addition they were
able to resign patty mills but it looked
like patty mills would be leaving town
that kyrie piece could
you know be the final flourish to the
sean mark's
you know reconfiguration of the roster
to give kevin durant a chance to assess
it look at it and say you know what yup
let's do these final four years that i
signed with in brooklyn because i think
i can win if i don't have the
distractions and i have a little bit
more talent around me why do you think
lebron feels like he could keep kyrie
under wraps and walk in the you know
straight and narrow with the lakers when
he couldn't do that with his best buddy
kevin durant
i i would say he did it with j.r smith
and i think that
someone like lebron
a bit of whether you want to call it uh
too much of a
self um
view of grandeur and being able to
handle these type of situations or not
that was a a pretty large undertaking he
got the best basketball of j.r smith's
career out of him in big time moments
and
i think lebron also recognizes that the
alternative
uh will not give him as much of a chance
to win uh you know the year one with
russell westbrook was an abject disaster
that's not all on russ of course because
there were major injuries to both lebron
and anthony davis and the rest of the
role players look at all those guys they
signed last summer there's like eight of
them who don't have a job at the nba
this year one year removed from being
the guys the lakers hand selected to put
around their big three to try to win a
championship they can't even get a sniff
of a contract right now and so it's not
just on russ of course but
it it it's clear to me that lebron sees
a better pathway to have a chance to
succeed in april till june when it
really matters with a guy like kyrie on
the side versus a guy like russell
westbrook
i'm amazed that the lakers were in
unison to bring in russ
as if they didn't see him in the other
stops that he had the last couple of
years
um
he's not a shooter
and he's not a triple double machine
that he once was i i'm just curious what
they saw
as to you know as as opposed to what
reality was because like kd said hey we
got james harden it's like wow man he's
not explosive
yes watch him play you can tell he's
he's going to explode because he's
getting larger but i'm just wondering
what they saw
as opposed to what they got with russell
westbrook
dan i think the theory was coming off
the season in which they played with the
short turnaround coming off the bubble
championship where lebron missed a bunch
of time and a.d missed a bunch of time
they figured as stars if we have a
adorable guy
beside us
the times when if we miss time which it
seems to be an inevitability at some
point when you're talking about a 37
year old lebron and a guy with injury
history and anthony davis and an 82 game
grueling schedule to get through that we
would have a guy who
his body has been
very durable and he's stayed in the
lineup now that was the correct
assumption by them russell westbrook
played 78 games last year and both
lebron and a.d missed significant time
where they didn't see the full picture
was
russell westbrook's game has severely
diminished as his athleticism has left
his body he hasn't made up for it in
adjusting his skill set and
quite frankly you mentioned he's not a
good shooter he's not a good defender
either way he's late he doesn't commit
any more to it i mean i i had somebody
with the lakers say that he just he he
gave up he quit playing defense
yeah he would die on screens they felt
like you know the one area he was a plus
defender was
in the post but you don't see very teams
very many teams posting up these days
that's not what the you know
three
spread out the floor type of offense
that you see
and so the other areas
against direct drives against pick and
roll coverage the things that you see
often against high-level nba offenses he
was not performing not even at an
average level like he was performing
near the bottom of the barrel when it
comes to defensive analytics and so so
what is he actually providing uh you
can't
maximize lebron's game with him because
lebron thrives around shooters which
grips in spacing well
the defenders can sag off of russ
on the offense when the lakes are on
offense because he can't shoot and then
on the opposite end
teams are exploiting him as a defender
yeah it's a tough combo to move forward
with yeah
uh
you surprised steph curry's hosting the
espys
yeah i was i was now one thing that
maybe
the background here that makes it all
makes sense is that i was told that he's
working on a documentary and um
you know this was a nice little chapter
to add to it right he already has the
most epic championship of his four that
he achieved in june
and you can have the whole
as i start to put one foot out
with one foot in in the basketball world
as i
view a life in entertainment or life as
being steph curry capital s capital c
for the rest of my days in super bowl
commercials and things like this is a
smart move and then the warriors are
going to be going over japan
uh in the preseason and they can
have the documentary crew uh follow
uh you know international superstardom
of steph curry so i think it kind of
fits in that whole arc
uh to do this and quite frankly he's
very comfortable uh with the camera on
it yeah i wondered if this is a business
relationship that's starting with the
mothership uh kobe did this uh
payton did this
maybe this is something that steph's
going to be doing four or five years
down the road where he's got content for
uh the mothership uh golden state's
roster how different will it look
opening night
yeah they
quite frankly haven't had a wonderful
offseason they lose a guy like gary
payton the second who was really good
for them at the defender otto porter who
goes to toronto also had some really big
moments in the playoffs the elite goes
overseas
um you know you have wanted scott
anderson for the lakers right now
the michael green
um
inevitability that adrian wojnowski is
reporting he's going to get a buy out
from okc thunder and join them that's a
nice piece to add they got a kid in the
draft who was really highly ranked
coming into college suffered some
injuries and and so he should be a guy
um
that that should help them and then they
are going to rely on guys like james
wiseman moses moody uh
and the like that was young prospects
that they've added the last couple years
to get better but
you know they can't say that they had as
good of offseason as say like the
clippers or the denver nuggets uh
these teams are going to be knocking on
the door in the western conference
trying to catch them at their heels
do you want me to get your tickets to
the espys
no dad i'm gonna stay home and watch
some netflix but i appreciate the uh
yeah cuz i got lifetime seats at the
espys i mean i i spent 18 years there
they they gave me they gave me two
lifetime seats
well i mean i couldn't turn down the the
dan patrick seeds if that's what's being
offered but you know
well ones they're not seated together
just so you know they're like
there's
like one in row five and then there's
one all the way up you know really
really high so if if you have a plus one
or you are a plus one i'm just saying
you won't be seated next to uh you know
brian windhorst i can't i can't just
come with you
oh no i i'm not invited to go to the
espys
they don't let me in but they'd like to
leave an empty seat in memory of me
yeah
there you go
your seat truly can't be filmed so let's
just say oh well done dave uh hey thanks
for joining us and uh enjoy the off
season
i appreciate it thank you that's dave
mcmenamin espn nba reporter